how can I help
well I don't I'm really trying to get
myself out of debt and I'm in a rut and
I'm really don't know where to begin
so I really need some advice of where to
even start gotcha okay how much do you
make weekly about $500 so your monthly
take-home pay is roughly $2,000 mm-hmm
and you're single
I am single mom single mom how many kids
one 16 year old okay you get child
support - I do and that's about that
just got reduced um that's about a
thousand dollars a month okay she about
three thousand a month to work on then
does he pay a pretty regular no that's
the problem
I'm nine so we can't count on it all
right and how much hate it but he
doesn't pay it on time which causes me
to be late on things so not you and how
much is your rent I'm fortunate I don't
have rent I'm trying to I'm living with
somebody my fiance and he is not
charging you a penny and picking on some
of the sharing some of the bills a
helical bills so when are you getting
married that's that then it's not soon
we want to do I want to clear my debt
and how much debt do you have uh between
personal loans and just back pan and
bills it's about twenty thousand okay
she have bad old bills is that what
you're saying yeah not in collection or
anything just late on what some utility
bills and things like that on the house
you're living in or the old from where
you moved where I'm who I'm living with
and he's also come to a different
financial state with his job as well
where his pay is reduced so he's
struggling to help me catch up on mine
but it's just okay I'm confused you live
in his house for free but you're paying
the utilities some of the utilities and
he's paying the others in the mortgage
and you're behind
on the ones you're supposed to be paying
yes how far uh about probably five
hundred dollars okay and um and that
brings utilities current okay and then
what kind of debt do you have um that
was about well about twenty you said
that earlier including all the back row
so that's including this five hundred
you're saying so what is the twenty on a
personal debt some family members I also
um remembers how much do family members
that's about fifty I didn't expect to
actually talk to you is just so I don't
have these numbers in front of me okay
and how much do you owe on your car I
don't
okay so fifteen thousand approximately
two family members is there anything
else like credit cards student loans L
credit cards student loans I am none
okay so far all I've got utilities and
family why okay all right well what
we're going to do is you need to you
need to lay out a written budget and the
first thing you buys food the second
thing you do is get current with the
lights and the water and the utilities
and you should be able to do that you
make enough to do those two things okay
if you don't do anything else but those
two things and you need to stay out of a
restaurant you can't afford to go out to
eat you're broke and you can't plan a
vacation you're broke well okay we don't
do and then you get organized and you
have two to three thousand dollars a
month coming in and all you've got to
buy is some food and utilities a little
bit of car gas yeah I just get
curveballs throwing my son he he goes in
he's in the scouting and he's also in a
lot of activities with school and I
don't want to deny him so I get thrown
curveballs with that oh I can deny him
the words no he lives with single mom
who's broke I don't want to miss out on
opportunities honey
you're broke your lights are about to be
cut off okay I don't give a crap about
his opportunities he needs
food shelter and clothing that's his
opportunity first and foremost you've
got to get organized and you cannot be
medicating his little life over there
you're not a rich person you have $2,000
a month to work with it's precious few
dollars so you know is about to enter
this young man's life and by the way
it's going to be good for him your mama
told you no my parents told me no none
of us died from it I never told the
counselor one time you know my life is
wrecked because my parents told me no
that never did that one time so I you
know reality is about to join this young
man's life and that's a good thing I'm
not saying you can't do anything but
you're gonna have to limit it you're you
don't have any money and you're 500
dollars behind on your utilities but by
God all his activities are paid come on
now stop that so alright now we're gonna
we're going to put his own thing under
control you've only got five hundred
dollars to catch up you make $2,000 a
month you got to buy some food and you
need to get your utilities current those
are your first things you prioritize and
then you begin to walk down and say how
I'm going to begin to pay back some of
these relatives and get these things out
of my life and every time the ex
actually does pay child support that's
extra money and you just throw that at
one of the debts and you know in about a
year and a half you could be completely
debt free with the current situation
you're living in if you can maintain it
and but you're going to have to control
your spending to do that and I suggest
you jump on every dollar calm it's our
online budgeting tool it is free to use
and jump on there and build yourself a
budget it takes about ten minutes and
make your money behave the problem is is
that life is telling you what to do and
you stood are you telling life what to
do and when you change that you're going
to change everything hey you guys
Rachael Cruz here hope you are enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show and did you know
that I have my
own YouTube channel yes that's right
kind of better than the Dave Ramsey
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you